all right Commodore tell me to her you
grow up from early
I'm originally from Wichita Kansas I
came out to California when I was 2
years old until we put your family yeah
both your my parents my mom she's her
from Wichita Kansas she um
my dad met her by coming through
Oklahoma he would go through Kansas City
they met he's on the side here on the
train because back then they couldn't
really afford it so he sent us down on
the train and he met us down here we
grew up I grew up on 119 Evaline and
after finishing an elementary school I
ring sighted at a Roosevelt in Compton
and that's where I started doing my
growing up it
I grew up up there that's I got the
Whaley guy started wearing suspenders
and hats they had this game the thing
was to beat up on white people every
Friday you don't have fights with the
whites it wasn't that many I'm going to
school but um if I wanted to be a blood
a guy in China dog created this game and
he was close to be my big homie and my
initiation was to go whoop on somebody
but it didn't go their way I got worked
on but they let me in as I got older I
thought gangs was just a a competitor
type game that who-who neighborhood can
have the most money who's the heart is
not in like dominating just killing
people you know as I got older I am went
to high school that's where all my bad
story beginning I started coming up by
the VA surely I did some things that I'm
not even proud of right now to this day
I've been baptized three times I get the
certificates thinking that I'm not gonna
ever make it to heaven man be you know
to take a person's life that's priceless
you know
my daughter life got to him our brother
was carrying her and she was 11 months
old they brought her down here on a
surprise when I was supposed to come
home from the service I was in the Navy
that's the branch I was in you know I
wanted to see her so bad but he went
from party every party when I got to
Compton from San Diego graduating in San
Diego every party that I went to they
said he just left he got your daughter
he just left
I had $1,000 for him I just took it out
the credit union and that was in 79 that
was a lot of money and um we went from
party and then we just passed this
street because my sister said we said we
don't go to the Carolina West it was
eight of us 773 Kremmling all gang
members ladies and we had a shotgun in a
car we got the dog in the car we went to
this was getting ready to go home to
take my sister to get her shoes but as
we was going home was coming down Long
Beach Boulevard this was December 22nd
1979 this was around 11 o'clock the
11:15 I still had on my uniform and we
looked down the street it was a gang of
police on the street right by Luther
sport we've seen a guy laying in the
street by a car we thought he was
working on it so we turned down this
street where the police was it we went
all the way up to this person the person
looked us in his face
we looked us in the facing and all a man
you are a man why are you blocking the
road when we backed up the police told
us to get up out of there Shearson as we
were leaving he's going on without
window what's wrong with you why he just
laying here in the street this is where
my little sister telling me my older
sister sitting by the door so we get
home and pull up in the driveway for her
to get her shoes and one mother come to
the door I said mama we couldn't find
Duke out the party was cloudy at that
was my baby's name my mother said y'all
need to go to the hospital they just
called he said Duke guys shut but to
make the story short on our way to the
hospital it's a club called the brothers
that son it says
so it's this close and as we was going
right it's Club I was driving this car
just pulled out in front of us at it no
way bang I mean [ __ ] we was flying to
the hospital I jumped out the car to go
see if this guy was alright
cuz I'm carrying my own burden when I
was ready to take off cuz we knocked him
out we knocked him well it just happened
I couldn't do nothing not even blink my
eye looking at my sister um there was a
funny - - worried but it was fine
so I rented this car to see if he was
already I said mister but I guess he was
so I was coming aggressively he pulled a
gun on me man and grabbed him and I was
like oh man so I magnin I'm just the kid
18 years old
no I'm 17 come on moving aside for me
boys and now you said man what's wrong I
said now I'm just going to the hospital
my brother just got shot so we've been a
hurry Superman him alright y'all going
and go the car Road but every time you
hit a bump it thinned it was it was a 73
gremlin
so when we get up to the hospital damn
know the police came and as we talked to
the police which his name was Brad Renji
he was on Suge Knight's also on Suge
Knight's uh payroll Reggie came and said
I said Reggie wear my suit who sent man
we got to the hospital I don't know who
was right who was wrong but my brother
just got shot and I just kinda mean I
thought he'd send me a whole lot of
people get shot tonight he said a guy
just got shot down the street and I'm
like what you mean am I supposed to say
who he say some little black dude about
your height man you say you got shot so
he just died and this is when he said
that a paramedic to him buddy the man
turned to her he didn't say nothing
about a child he said nothing about a
child but to make a long story short
that guy that our
rolled up on I didn't see the baby
because they've removed the move the
baby from that was my brother I was
talking to but he couldn't talk it was a
lady behind the gate the same time with
these grapevines only she was
communicating with him for a whole hour
he laid in the street he was shot eight
times with a 30 I see close range up on
the door and he was holding the baby my
baby was messed up man I came home on
emergency meet this is where my own my
career asked me and the servicemen which
is my Navy Eagle right and my triangle
my career as a big guy just a left right
there my daughter my brother I can shoot
a distance without a scope will and they
seen it in the service too I shoot birds
and stuff a guy came up missing by
school a girl hit a guy pulled up in a
car pulled a gun under the truck she
said he said it on the gate he shot
across the school and left jumped in the
car and left he was driving with some
wrenches which was ace trying to say a
pair of vise grip she said well they
angled the direction that this guy was
shooting was just supposed to be me she
said I put a rifle on the game and shot
him a dice game but she said I went
shooting she said I shot one time they
say the guy grabbed the back of his head
and failed on the other side of the
school they said this guy just got in
the car and he left then another guy
these are supposed to been the guy that
was in the car there was three people in
the car and all the names was in the
paper another guy got shot in the face
that they're like so um that's what we
call quick me at work I had friends that
was from my neighborhood they wanted to
deliver but I did my own I paid my own
they came up and started investigating
my case I am and the way they put the
story together is like nudist Park is a
known game ready Bluff Crips
is a known game it's gonna be a
retaliation a dude and his kid and then
curing a good little girl got shot so
they already know how to retaliation
bail but it's just a matter of time a
win so they started doing this
investigation and I guess they say well
let me see this guy got any brothers and
stuff like this and next thing you know
I get a plane I get an unexpected visit
in San Diego they told me I have to go
to the legal office and talk to somebody
so I dismissed myself from my company
which was gonna do a swimming drilling I
left and well when any I get kind of
nervous of things cuz I already know let
me see if I can just be cool
cladius up cuz I know it I know what
this is about man they said we'll come
loose tomorrow we have a guy like murder
and wounded whoop and this guy has been
shot in the back of the neck through the
back through the neck through the hidden
I said um and you know it's funny he
said it just like that he said you know
it's fine you'd only want to shoot like
that
and you was at home own emergency need
the Red Cross you go your papers doing
the time this guy got shot that's a
[ __ ] it's a nice right here smell it
so what would make you think on shooting
dude like that I can shoot a BB gun you
know I'm playing Snoopy
it looks like a see me really easy I got
Joey I said no you don't so the way they
did me man I thought I wouldn't gonna
see you in them work they sent me to a
general court-martial in a service the
service said we want to deal with our
own so they sent me to a general
court-martial but we wouldn't be as
something else before I got arrested we
went back to these guys neighborhood
there was a or ar-15 there's a lot of
guns involved a lot of people got hurt
you know that was just how we're
celebrating in those are deep scars from
both sides of crypt guys that I knew
that were blue rags and I mean real
notorious gangs and this is where we get
our stripes said they say I have a name
of a leader instead of calling me
general they just call him the Commodore
by my first name because it's a leading
officer that's the same way that is in
the dictionary
I know what my name mean so they ranked
me out and we ain't supposed to live to
be 58
oh you don't die about 26 27 if you
don't get light I went to prison
I served 26 and a half years I started
off for San Diego in a brief they
convicted but with a-b-c-d not a
dishonorable a bad kind of this chart so
they transferred me to San Diego I
stayed in their brief which was bad
because I never did time in my life and
I was still young and I just didn't like
threw my life away so they transferred
me from San Diego to Great Lakes
Illinois and Great Lakes in Lewis a brig
up there and from there they transform
raft ideas seven seven years seven and a
half years so almost eight years you
know I don't know the name of Great
Lakes Illinois brick but it's son it's a
big one
they transfer me to the feebs did he
levy in the fears I promoted out of
calipari state prison that's how they
broke my time up I pro 2008 having
affected me I started coming down here I
started buying [ __ ] and smoking crack
cocaine cuz I've my equal liver felt
like it was [ __ ] up
I was I'm bad excuse my language split
my life just went balanced man you just
I didn't think that I would be living in
that fade gesture oh I'm a gang member
and every word that came on my mouth
with blood blood but some guys say
there's a front
I said because I mean it you know and I
am Hiromi it's my big oh okay her old
man is my big homie from another sport
alright yeah if you made me walk big
walk straight yeah we call them
gangsters Hey he raised me but um if I
can take a lot of things back I ain't
scared to say this on camera because you
gotta prove it there's five eyes missing
probably morning Nick I just never
stayed to see it's like I got a dreaming
doing it but I think God show favor with
me I believe in God
I wish I could take these things back
man the hurt that we put on people I
heard that you have to put on yourself
when you're doing and thinking it's
gonna be cool but it's not really cool
to watch a person died you know it's not
cool it's not cool to shoot nobody
every time I get a chance to try to help
somebody today I try I try to help them
in because I [ __ ] up I did and I can
roll this film to next year with some
serious [ __ ] if I out been raised I can
raise big show tonight
he's my little home from the report two
parts he got killed all this [ __ ] it was
retaliation of all it's just like when
he got killed the night to pie got
killed look what happened the conflict
our neighborhood gets together they
stupid 25 and this you can see I know
you can look that up you you y'all do
your homework 25 people within one hour
like you if the lights all that the
light is Chris did anybody that
represent a bad boy was just did they
put Compton on lockdown
but what I see right now and is my
daughter man I'm 58 years old right now
got stuck down here I was strung out
over rock cocaine
I was buying buying smoking in car women
beat me they beating me bad I'm going to
the clinic getting shots damn in the
back of the neck you know I can't pee
right you know it's good but I lived
that life man that's the life that I
chose man I was down here since the
eighties and I watched a lot of people
go down here the same way it's a lot of
notorious gang members down here me day
when they say they don't care they don't
but they have a lot of respect and it's
just come a long way since um I'm kind
of glad and I think I'll take that
police on the street too I used to
finish dinner lovely when they hit the
corner man saving my ass man I'm taking
good to go on like that Mouser say it's
funny how you can go from a bad guy the
bad boys stereotype tire you want to say
it tell you the guy that just won't
piece this no problems with nobody man I
don't know there's another that's
another side of me I don't like this
side likes I've been baptized three
times this little guy got papers up in a
gym over at the midnight 153 pound
over at the lion guard eighth floor
maxed everybody out at a hundred no 440
on the bench and I only weighed 148 won
three gold medals
this little guy took with the Navy he
told him the Adolphus is [ __ ] with you
know it wasn't by choice it was because
I lost my daughter so
I think I've been I've been doing
alright
I still don't know how to express myself
to being isolated so long sometimes the
way I even talked just normally and my
expression always stay like this people
get it misconstrue is you know they
think that something wrong with me I do
from another point you should say hi to
him you go flap [ __ ] out of your self
you know but I'm not you know me a bit
we don't forsake them but I always had
it look like this you know because
that's just I got a habit of watching
people marry I could feel people to just
want to have a normal life and you know
sometime I don't think my life would be
normal until I'm dead girl because it's
the things and the thoughts that that
that was left behind the distilling ass
in here
I still see some people's family members
you know so say if I could take back
some things I would I think some things
that my friends did I see something that
was dear to my friends we weren't always
the one the tough month to get away
during my school years I wish my mom was
here to tell you all my friends is
basically dead
how old I went to his funeral we went to
funeral was like we go to parties if
anybody here did they gonna tell you I'm
seriously and I know you probably heard
him more than one time that's how he is
in the game we don't ever get the clone
this always said guess who died guessing
dude he got killed last night but you
never thought you were here your brother
in your daughter me telling my neighbors
it was glad to see me
I hate he come running to me come come
today no we all just coming from the
hospital because my daughter and my
brother got cute and it was like what's
wrong with you man ain't you overwhelmed
the son and we told him not to get
killed last night which it would find
you and they just fell out
it's just like my mom them I never
thought they were that I thought they
would just live everything with my
heroes you know your mom and dad oh you
like your daughter and your brother
maybe this might have been a good
hideout for me but this is a place down
here where you could just nut to [ __ ] up
an angle you pay you don't mind you know
still not high you it's funny you go
stand on the sidewalk and holler
pissed at the same time and throw
something bipolar it's just gonna keep
going no see I when we come back around
do it somewhere else
just two clocks away from done and they
gonna tackle yours
you know they let you get aggressive
with yourself and look at you the game
go
[ __ ] y'all hit a crack pipe rain frenum
they just laugh and drive up you know I
don't these people don't need man but
what I need some time every night I mean
even a little bitty dude like me just
need a hug every now and again this
shows some people some love and that's
all they need that's all these people
made this community ain't nothing wrong
with down here just a little of Martin
you know that's about my story you know
I'm looking forward man it every time I
get a chance to try to encourage
something I do I do it even in my
drawings man I just I just like to see
people do better I didn't want to get
better at bay older
I ain't gonna get bigger get over and
just tell people just a story I want to
tell you from experience because when
I'm dead and gone I want to leave some
type of legacy like you doing the
photographer you know something I had a
little ride ever you know it was just a
little office rental off for if you know
anything about San Bernardino it was oh
it was orange to go and water me they
had these little off your trainer $307 I
turned one into an art gallery that was
my little like you have every man and
yes so we're not bringing some guys from
down here gang members what they do
kick the door in thinking I was in it my
singing friends man got him on camera
but I couldn't go to court I couldn't
press charges I wouldn't be walking
around we not allowed to call the police
so that's my life story mark I don't you
know I noticed oh one more thing is I
was writing a friend his name is ah he
from my area and um I know he got a deal
with a lot of birds they just his friend
shot my friend in a part in our part
embarrassed him and let the gun like
boom boom boom shot him all in the face
and the good night jam back smoke the
girls thought it broke but I said nah he
jammed back it cost that man his family
for trying to be impressive trying to be
a gay man people how they kill somebody
we're never thinking about what goes on
with lurks right by him doing it that
Park is so many people in powerful gangs
they went over to his house open the
door killed his mama cutie zion.t killed
his brother killed his sister killed
everybody know that type of [ __ ] you
know so when I was in prison it's this
this is striking nervous how you
encourage somebody you wanna gang member
you want a hardcore gang members you go
in jail
the shortest person on New York besides
me that was going coming home was myself
and he get out in 2069 that's the
earliest dude on the yard
they got EPR IDs which me early as
possible release date 3016 7020 without
a life sitting you know this is what
happens when you pull the trigger when
you take somebody like we don't take
your life but we don't take your life
mentally you say you can handle it
I've seen guys Andrew
only to thought that was when you get it
at five years just like a plane hitting
[ __ ] turbulence you start breaking
apart coming apart after five you start
coming apart I never thought I was gonna
come it's these are three ways you gonna
come out of there to wise like they was
telling me they were school to me
because it was tricky when I went to
prison
guys with ten hey homie come on you name
the shooter getting a diamond old homie
ain't know why you turned you hear they
try to knock you up like my homeboy he's
the guy you've been seeing on TV if you
remember him story the buff the guy get
the police put in his cell and he raped
that every guy in court were great day
tomorrow night today dreaming tomorrow
his name was remade today you call
yourself layman but tomorrow you send it
over your mouth
my name is Raina Oh Renee you know it
was funny it happened like that it was
happening just like that these are game
rivers this is what your friends talked
about you you put in all that work you
hard yeah I'm gonna know what a homeboy
did they'd be calling you Tabitha the
more you know they they did not care
mandate it um but he told me
gangster nice it is only three ways you
can come out of prison and I'm a little
dude that's they didn't want this little
ass right here you big man try to run so
I used to always do push up this is why
I got so strong um they tell me that uh
it's three ways you can come up and you
better you better not a new music you
better not [ __ ] up Commodore wise a
homosexual or in a box been the only
three ways you can come home and he say
yo Troy so he reached in the back they
treated the cheeks of his ass game a
gang of balloons we we balloons he said
here I get yourself right in here I'm
gonna bring you some kind of mood i'ma
bring you did he kept looking at me
always do it mouth like there
look we may be looking at you like that
like you ain't [ __ ] everything I'm just
finished
I'm gonna wear how you say that what's
the worry Julie say now I [ __ ] you but
I'm a rape viewer my very ugly you don't
see them looking at you licking your
lips and [ __ ] yeah come on move with me
any time they saying [ __ ] like that
boldly nice man [ __ ] you mixing what you
do and you're looking at him cuz they
been in there for a while you mean you
looking like a Stan chicagee do like
this he's walk away he may be like Jack
yeah Joey joking Bernie ain't jokin good
guy do not give up
[ __ ] about us that's in prison they
don't want to hear your story they only
another bump outside they just want to
get out so that's what I get all right
coming right thank you for sharing your
startin mmm that's my story
you